اعتقاري والدك وموكلك محمد زيان مساء امس
ما هي التهام التي اودينا بسببها
[موسيقى]
الذي قال بان والدي النقيب محمد زيان تم
اطلاق سراحه في المرحله الابتدائيه
[موسيقى]
كفاله هذا امر غير صحيح من الاصل كان قرر
الوكيل الملك
وقرر بعد التفكير والتشاور مع النقيب زيان
انه من الاشجر ان تقدم الاستئناف واستئنا
الحكم الا ان من الطبيعي
المبدا مبدئيا المسطره تقتضي ان في حاله
خلال سريان اجل الطعن بالنقد اللي هو 10
ايام واذا وقع على النقد خلال الارض الملف
امام محكمه النقض يبقى المتهم ولو صدر
في في في حاله صراحه نهائيا
الا ان هناك استثناء في الماده 392 على 94
لا تذكر رقم بالضبط من قانون المدنيه الذي
يسمح للوكيل العام الوكيل الملك
[موسيقى]
غالبا انا ليس ليست لي احصائيات ولكن في
في تجربه متواضعه كمحامي اييي غالبا عن
المحكمه تستجيب الى مثل هذه الملتزمسات
وهو امر مؤسف لان في الاخير تبقى
بشكل عنه
[موسيقى]
لا انا شخصيا لم استطيع
امر غريب ثاني هو ان ااا
وجدت صعوبات في حصول على اذن بالزياره في
السجن واخيرا سلمه سلمه لي السيد الوكيل
العام بعد بعد مناقشه دامت بعد ساعات
في الرابعه ونصف لم استطيع الوصول
ساظره غدا ولكن احد الزملاء الذي كان له
اكثر حد مني حصل على هذا اليد صباح اليوم
وازره واكد لانويته جدا مرتفعه وانه يتمسك
بمواقفه وما قاله ولا لا يتراجع على كلامي
خياراتكم انتم همم في هيئه الدفاع عنه ما
ستكون
همم تقنيه هناك
حل واحد وهو الطعن بالنقد في في القرار
الذي صدر يوم امس
لكن الان لا يمكن ان اقرضنا دون المشاوره
في الاخير هو الذي
يقرر
[موسيقى]
اظن بان والدي جيدا اعتقد بان غالبا سنقرر
سيقرر الطعام بالنقد وسنقوم به في اقرب
وقت كما اننا لن نتردد دقيقه من دقيقه من
اللجوء الى جميع المصادر التي تفتح
المفتوحه لنا قانونيا بما في ذلك المساقه
الدوليه وهذا حقك اشكرك من جديد جزيلا
شكرا من رباط الاستاذ علي رضا نجلاء
المحامي السابق محمد زيان ومحامي كلها
شكرا لك على تربيه دعوتنا هذا المساء